JUST A FEW POINTS OUT FROM THE
RODRIGUEZ TO THE INSIDE.
NOT EVEN COVID.
THE ADVANTAGE OF BEING A RIGHT
SHOT.
IN FRONT.
AND IT IS ARE CHANGING.    PLAY
ELEVATING OVER THE RIGHT.
KRIS LETANG WITH A
KRIS LETANG GOES OFF.
OFF THE HAS BEEN VERY
GOOD THIS SEASON.
THE MVP.
VLASIC, ANOTHER DEFENSEMAN.
KNOCKING IT DOWN.  YEAR DEAL.
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED TO THE SAN
JOSE SHARKS.
KASPER BJORKQVIST.
A BOUNCE.
GOES UP HIGH.
TO LANE PEDERSON.
MISSING IT.
JOHN MARINO WITH A SHOT.  6-1.
BRYAN RUST IS.
TO O'CONNOR.
O'CONNOR BY O'CONNOR.THE DECISI
>> STEVE: AND THE SHARKS SCORE
JUST 20 SECONDS TON.
MEIER.
MEIER TO ERIK KARLSSON.  IT BEH
AN
ON THE ATTACK.
STICK UP.
BACK OVER.  .
LOOK AT ALL THE PENGUINS
FOCUSED ON THE PUCK AND NOBODY
AND THEN RODRIGUES TAKES IT UES
BRYAN RUST.
AND HE HAS THE FINAL TO